Alice and Bob have figured out an
amazing trick they are exchanging
messages by plucking a wire either hard
or soft to transmit a zero versus a one
however due to gusts of wind false zeros
or ones can occur during transmission
resulting in errors though they figured
out a way to communicate error-free even
in the presence of noise how could they
do this
in the 1940s Richard Hamming faced a
similar problem while working at Bell
Laboratories at the Bell Telephone
laboratories we do about 10% of the
experiments on a computer in about 90%
in laboratory I'll expect it in time we
will do 90% on the computer and 10% to
the lab speed cost and effort favor the
computer over the laboratory approach at
the time the computers used stored
information on punch cards representing
one versus zero with whole versus no
hole
this system was error-prone because it
was common for cards to get bent or miss
punched in the first place so holes
could be missed or no holes could be
accidentally punctured causing flipped
bits these errors would cause the entire
system to halt until the error location
could be found and corrected manually so
Hamming took it upon himself to devise a
method which could automatically detect
and correct single bit errors without
interrupting calculations his solution
was rooted in the intuitive idea of
repetition something we all do when
faced with interference or the chance
that part of our message will be
corrupted
his error correcting codes were built on
the simple concept of a parity bit a
parity bit is a single bit which is
added to the end of a message and
indicates whether the number of ones in
the message is even or odd
if a single error occurs the receiver
can then detect it
because the parity bit will no longer
match however to detect and correct
single errors hemming needed to add more
parity bits to identify the error
location this leads to his 7/4 code
which adds three parity bits to each
block of four data bits as follows first
we start with the three parity bits
which can be represented by a circle now
these circles intersect to produce four
regions and the four data bits are
placed inside these regions in a
specific order now to calculate the
parity bits we look at each circle one
at a time each containing three data
bits we determine the parity bit as
before add up the data bits and if we
get zero or two the parity bit is zero
for even and if we get one or three the
parity is one for odd and we do this for
all circles and end up with three parity
bits to match the four data bits these
are then placed in a standard sequence
as follows
realize now this system can
automatically correct single errors with
a simple rule if a single error occurs
two or more of the parity bits will be
incorrect and wherever they intersect is
the location of the error this
intersecting data bit is then flipped
automatically so that all parity bits
are valid again and this is Alice and
Bob's trick the additional parity bits
are known as redundant bits because they
don't carry any new information and all
error correction codes work this way
they all increase the size of the source
messages slightly at the expense of
automatically correcting errors we also
use error correction codes for storage
for example on a physical CD the
information is encoded using special
codes to correct for chunks of errors
caused by scratches or dust which
corrupt longer sequences of zeros and
ones stored on the surface this is why
you can scratch a CD and often it will
still play perfectly Claude Shannon use
this idea of redundancy to redefine the
capacity of a communication channel
because as the noise on your channel
increases we must increase the amount of
redundancy to communicate error-free and
this must then decrease the effective
amount of information you can send per
unit time